no importa los ataques continuos sobre
gersón tal como lo hace todos los días
ni la ha venido a ayudar a espetlana de
77 años que no puede moverse por su
cuenta después de que tuvo una caída
hace tres meses
svetlana se quedó sola cuando su hija y
sus nietos se fueron huyendo de la
invasión rusa en gersón que se extendió
durante ocho meses en aquel momento la
mujer llamó a la organización a la que
pertenece Lila y pidió que cuidaran de
su madre
[Música]
Lila es una de las tantas mujeres y
hombres que Durante este último año han
dedicado su vida a ayudar a los
habitantes de la ciudad especialmente
personas mayores y niños ocupada
es difícil compramos todo por nuestra
cuenta nadie nos da una bombilla ni
cobijas ni pañales es como si jerson
guardara silencio
lidera la entrega de ayuda humanitaria
más de mil niños y sus familias que
permanecen en la ciudad
hay niños que tienen miedo de salir
miedo a los tiros hay niños que ya han
empezado a tartamudear
[Música]
su trabajo como voluntario es solo una
de sus facetas también es el director de
uno de los hogares que cuidan de niños
que se han quedado sin padres en este
vídeo muestra el día que los oficiales
rusos llegaron al centro En búsqueda a
los niños que para entonces él había
logrado reubicar en casas de sus
familias
logró proteger a 46 niños y adolescentes
y evitar que fueran llevados a Rusia si
volviera a suceder me quedaría un 100%
con los niños y Haría todo lo posible
para sacarlos
y miles de personas que han pasado a
convertirse en héroes en este último año
en Ucrania